raised by like white americans he was
raised by other koreans who immigrated
here
but um
did it remind you of your dad because
[Music]
it's like a [ __ ] up still always trying
to do his message yes
yes yeah yeah so when was going back
towards like the reasons why he kept
antonio makes these bad decisions um it
makes perfect sense to me too um
whether it be a case of like a massive
fear of abandonment um and in five four
three two
one hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius
another episode of the genius brain
podcast we have been your friends every
thursdays and sundays and this is just
really fun conversation man we're just
here chopping it up having a good
[ __ ] time i have my host today
with me
ed park of ed park vp here that's a
long hair don't care
yeah man i i've always been thinking
about cutting it for a while i haven't
cut it since
valentine's day 2020. really and then
like the month after covet hit like
right around the time i should have got
a haircut and i haven't cut it since i
wish i could grow my hair like you i
can't do it my hair's too
fine it's just straight it's just
straight and too fine and it just looks
like japanese [ __ ]
it does not look good at all yeah i get
lucky with the little bit of the
the little waves at the end it looks
like where did you get your hair done
[Music]
wash it and blow dry it yeah that's it
from god himself yeah you know um did
you ever get into uh mukbangs
a little bit yeah there's some times
where it's just like
something i i can't turn away sometimes
like when i watch people there's certain
mukbangs that i don't [ __ ] like man
there's ones where um
people chew with their mouth open
or they talk with them i want to go into
the screen and choke them alive
[Laughter]
it's so bad
number one i just don't like people
chewing with their mouth open in the
first place yeah i think it's [ __ ]
obnoxious i think it's disgusting yeah
frankly
second thing i don't like about it
reminds me of my dad
my dad it's a nerve would chew with his
mouth open ferociously dude
and
just non-fucking stop he doesn't really
do it as much now i think my mom made a
comment about it just chewing with his
mouth oh but you would think this fool
was a camel in a past life like my
[ __ ] word guy like are you not
getting enough oxygen
and what he would say is like it just
makes the food taste better which i
think is like a chinese korean or just
asian thing in general i've heard about
that like burping at the table undoing
your buckle your belt buckle is a sign
of wow that was a great meal yeah it's
like with japanese people when you slurp
your noodles right it's it's a sign that
you you're enjoying your meal it's a
compliment and also too like the air and
everything else and like makes your food
taste better when you suck it in and it
cools down the noodles as well so
there's a good thing about it but my dad
would chew his [ __ ] [ __ ] so loud dude
i remember i got my ass beat one time
so i was doing my homework right and my
dad he has a very odd way of trying to
connect to his kids it's never him
coming in saying hey how was your day
today or what you're doing
he just does things in just the most
socially absurd way so he just comes in
into my room no knock no nothing comes
in and i'm doing my homework he leans
over puts his hand on my desk puts one
against my seat he's like rocking me and
he's just chewing gum
what are you doing yeah
yeah
like
i'm like i'm doing my homework right now
he goes
wouldn't it
just imagine somebody chewing like big
red gum in your ear
and i'm like his presence i looked at my
dad and i was like appa you're chewing
so loud in my ear
he's like why are you in such a bad mood
and then he's your fault he'll be upside
my head and he goes out to get a stick
to beat my ass and i'm like
oh my god
i had to get my listen to gum being
chewed in my ear adam get my ass beat
yeah it's like no you're in the wrong
day can't you see i'm like yo what the
[ __ ] man it's because you put him in a
bad mood i was just standing here right
in my business or you're an [ __ ]
exactly so he had to come through and
beat my [ __ ] ass dude like if i just
go through all this this
if i could just tally every time i got
my ass beat for and i didn't know the
reason why
it's so many it's like sometimes i would
just walk in the house and i'm like yo
some shit's gonna happen oh you know
something is gonna [ __ ] happen i i
[ __ ] something up and it kind of
reflected in me and mary's relationship
in the beginning i used to be hyper
defensive about stuff sometimes right um
and so was she because we both grew up
in korean households where every time a
question is asked it's because they're
trying to figure out a way to beat our
ass
you know it's like if you're asking a
question that means you're already
dedicated to [ __ ] me up today yeah i
just don't know why yet yeah
you know so it's like oh
did you uh take out the trash today and
the first thing i think is i don't think
yeah i wonder if i did i think did i not
take out the trash and am i gonna get a
[ __ ] ass whooping right now so like
everything is done in fear yeah
everything is out of fear there's no
like
positive reinforcement right it's all
negative the reason why you do something
is so you don't die yeah pretty much you
gotta do this so you don't get your [ __ ]
kicked out not because it's a good
responsible thing to do
it's to the point now where i don't i'm
not very good with compliments right you
know i see a lot of like
you know whites do this very well
probably because they grew up in a world
where their parents when you did
something great they go good job you
know for what i'm going to learn have to
do is give verbal affirmation to my kids
in the future because i'm more like oh
you clean your room that's what you're
supposed to do
you know [ __ ] look for a pat on your
ass about this stuff right but it
doesn't really create this positive
um communication with your kids right i
i don't think anyways and i'm seeing
a lot of my friends do this with their
kids now when they do something great
they or do something good they give them
a compliment and let them know that
they're doing a great job right right
sometimes it's too excessive in my
personal opinion and a lot of people are
seeing this now with their kids where
these kids always get praised and they
never get chastised so when it comes to
you know facing adversity
they crumble right i i have a friend who
needed to know that they were doing a
good job and i was like why
you know and then you'd be like can i
get a hug for him like
no you know and they were genuinely hurt
yeah because they're more used to that
kind of reinforcement and i'm just like
what no like listen like i've you know
worked with people i worked with
somebody who told me
that she never
got yelled at by her parents once in her
life wow ever
how she turned out pretty good pretty
[ __ ] good yeah um i think she is i
think every kid's different i think she
was a pretty well-behaved kid like she
didn't just didn't stir up [ __ ] and
that's how she is now as an adult
and you would think this is an amazing
thing the only hard part about when i
used to work with this girl
was that the hard part was is that it is
impossible
for you to not [ __ ] up something right
you will [ __ ] up right people will bring
especially in a work environment people
are going to bring up the stuff that you
didn't do well so you can improve well
when somebody is over here sucking your
ass for a [ __ ] damn year 25 years of
your life 27 25 years of your life
and you're not used to people giving you
critique you think everything is gold
right you think everything that you do
is damn near amazing and so let's say we
were working on a project together or we
were going to you know write something
or do something
when you're in this creative space and
ed knows too not all of our ideas are
great and people will make new
suggestions how this person would take
it was i'm not adequate enough
um this person hates me why did they
feel that they needed the voices i feel
disrespected when it's really just hey
this is my opinion about something
they're so used to consistent praise
over everything and so sometimes when we
work on these projects these ideas
aren't great right and it fails well
guess what when we work on projects and
we do things sometimes
it's going to fail it's it's highly
possible if something is new
and so you know years ago when um
it was me and another guy that we were
working on this comedy project together
and didn't like her idea we thought like
hey maybe we should ship this with some
of the characters
she was just like hit us up after he was
like hey can i talk to you guys like i
just felt really disrespected today and
then both of us were like
what
and then she was like yeah like
you know i thought my ideas were great
and both you guys didn't like it i'm
like
excuse me
and so you know i had a long
conversation with her i'm like why do
you feel like you're being disrespected
she goes i just thought my idea was
great i was like cool
here's the thing and once again you
don't really know me that well but do
you know that your [ __ ] stinks
like when you [ __ ] it smells just like
my [ __ ] smells right
you are not above me i am not beneath
you we are all equal so when you have an
idea that we don't like that's not a
reflection on you as a person
individually yeah this is a workshop we
are working out ideas
90 of the stuff we put out is not going
to be great you grew up differently than
i did you and i have a different sense
of humor we're going to throw out ideas
and we're going to try things and we
feel like it doesn't work we're going to
vocalize it and then we're gonna meet
somewhere in the middle and create
something better yeah not all your ideas
are gold and if you think that we have
to
entertain every idea that you have just
because you personally feel affected
we're gonna sit here and waste time and
create garbage we need friction friction
creates growth yeah and so
we started talking and i was like i'm
not trying to be disrespectful there's
absolutely no way in this workspace that
you think that i'm being that i'm being
disrespectful and i think it's uncalled
for for you to have this the side
conversation about us disrespecting you
and if you tell other people this
because we had a disagreement a creative
disagreement
i don't understand why you feel this way
i was like was it the way that i said it
could i have changed the way that i said
it she goes no it wasn't like how you
said it i just felt disrespected that
you didn't think my idea was good i'm
like okay now i'm getting frustrated so
we had a conversation and she talked
about how she grew up never got yelled
at like when she
my parents never really disagreed with
anything that i did because my i was a
good kid
i'm not your parent
i'm not mommy and daddy you and i are
equals in this space when we work on
these ideas not every single idea that
you [ __ ] out of your ass is going to be
gold
same thing for me you don't like the
things that i do you speak the [ __ ] up
yeah don't agree go yeah that's great
you don't think it's great or you think
that something can be different say it
with
you know be polite about it you know
have tact
but you should disagree did you disagree
with some of the stuff like he goes yeah
i thought some of the character you
should have said that you shouldn't have
sat there and then just pray given me
praise which i already thought was
[ __ ] weird
you know i was like how are all these
ideas that i put out amazing yeah like
every single one yeah i'm like what is
this but then the other partner was
there and then he would be like ah that
doesn't make sense for characters like
let's switch this up a bit right so you
know it's just
i don't know did anyone make it there
did well
it's when people make it their hill to
die on like their idea is great and it's
the only way to go right yeah that
where it's like project will live or die
and
i've been in that situation where there
was this project i was part of this
company and the
network manager or was acting as a
producer
he was a he was four weeks late to a
deadline
right and then like
after about you know yeah that much time
they brought the project to me and i
didn't even know was happening
like uh and i was an internal editor
they brought it to me to fix right and
then they were like we've run out of
ideas
like
this is what the director or the
producer wanted and we they put all
those things in the video
but the client hates it they don't want
any of it like you got to fix this
right with no notes either what they the
client wants either
so you know i had to just take whatever
was shot and re-edit everything and do
my own text titles and do my own words
and all this stuff like my own copy
and then they approved that they liked
it and they put it up right
next thing i know that producer is in my
office
like comes in and he's like
how dare you i was like huh
yeah he's like you didn't do
anything that i said in my notes you
didn't do anything in the script like
you didn't listen to any of my
suggestions and now this video is up
online and it's nothing that i wanted
out of it
and
i was just like everything you wanted
made this project four weeks late
not accounting the time how much you had
before to make it yeah the weeks you had
before but the fact that you went an
extra four weeks later with all your
ideas and they were rejecting all of
them
i did what i had to do and he was like
he's used the word audacity he's like i
cannot believe this and he walked out
like
like i [ __ ] up the entire project when
the other network managers the
post-production supervisors they were
like thank you you saved this project we
still get to keep this client you know
so it's like
i had to read that [ __ ] like wow what a
[ __ ] cry baby yeah anything like that
he was just like
his issue was
i'm gonna get fired because of you
because i didn't do my job right you
know right and you did something that
actually saved his ass and instead he
would have been smart and been a regular
[ __ ] instead and just taking the
credit yeah
those were all my ideas i was used to
that yeah it's like why don't you just
do that instead that would have made
that would have made more sense yeah i
would have expected that yeah it's like
you know i just saved your job [ __ ]
yeah
that happened a lot yeah well today guys
we are going to do a movie review which
is highly requested by you guys um and
ladies and gents and women and men and
non-binary yeah and all of them are the
above yes i got to be very careful now
yeah everybody is what i'm trying to say
no disrespect um a blue bayou the film
now blue bayou is a film
that uh
my one of our personal friends justin
chan uh
wrote directed and was the lead actor in
this film also the
writer director of [ __ ] also the writer
director of [ __ ] yeah um
i personally thought this was an amazing
film
one of the things that's really i mean
shout out to auntie chang the dp yeah
shout out to reynolds the the lead
editor in this ray ray um shout out to
eunice the costume design
[ __ ] amazing
just everything about this film was
really great and once again i think a
lot of people are going to say well it's
because he's your personal friend this
is why you loved it so much
cool i didn't like miss purple a lot
yeah
i i haven't gotten to see it i
contributed to the [ __ ] uh fundraiser
too the kickstarter oh yeah i was
supposed to get a blue right here
okay i haven't seen him because it
wasn't next year
about that but um this podcast is
brought to you by for sig matic a
wellness company that is well known for
its delicious mushroom coffee now hold
on before you go ahead and judge me let
me explain to you how dope this is four
sigmatics mushroom coffee is real
organic fair trade single origin arabica
coffee with lion's mane mushroom for
productivity and chaga mushroom for
immune support see i start my day with
four sigmatic ground mushroom coffee
with lion's manes instead of regular
coffee because it helps me focus and get
my [ __ ] done mushroom coffee is also
easy on my gut and it doesn't leave me
with that awful jittery feeling or that
mid-day crash i if i'm going to go ahead
and do this i actually do this through
um cold brew i actually use a cold brew
situation with it i get a little cloth
put the four sigmatic mushroom coffee in
there and i steep it into the the water
for about a couple of days and then i
have cold brew in the morning ready to
go for the next few days until i run out
it's dope we've worked out an exclusive
offer with four sigmatic on their
best-selling mushroom coffee but this is
just for genius brain listeners get up
to 40
off plus free shipping on mushroom
coffee bundles to claim this deal you
must go to 4sigmatic.com
brain genius this offer is only for
genius brain listeners and is not
available on their regular website
you'll save up to 40 and get free
shipping so go right now to
4sigmatic.com brain genius and fuel your
productivity and creativity with some
delicious mushroom coffee it's very
heavy it's you're going to walk away
feeling something about this right
um if you guys want to know the
background to this it's a korean adoptee
story so
especially after 9 11
a lot of adoptees were getting deported
yes um i actually changed my name to
so original so for my whole life when i
first came to this country my parents on
my birth certificate had my name as
in cook so yeah my dad was so scared
that i was going to get deported because
that we were all going to get deported
that um
he wanted us to change our names and get
our citizenship immediately and it was
very [ __ ] expensive very easy to get
your citizenship by the way it's just
the process is really long the questions
are very simple
um to prove that you're an american even
though obviously when you hear me speak
i am [ __ ] american but my father was
so scared that we were going to get
deported that immediately when that [ __ ]
happened a few months later my dad was
like uh not a few months later but it
was like a few years later when he heard
these stories of like korean adoptees
and chinese chinese americans and even
people who are korean
that aren't adoptees that just
immigrated here early on that had a
green card were getting deported it
didn't matter what the [ __ ] it was yeah
so he got scared i got my american
citizenship i changed my name legally to
david and then my middle name um is now
uh
i can't believe my parents didn't give
me my korean name as my middle name i
just don't have one you don't have a
korean name at all well i i have one
chong hyun okay but then they didn't
make it my official middle name
meanwhile my sister's name is a korean
name i was like what you forget about
you know because
because you know you're loved that's why
same story dude yeah okay edward knows
he's loved his middle name
no yeah but um
i feel you on that like uh not just the
i've i've
seen a lot of um
yeah like
of my friends who aren't uh born in
america get
sent off to back to korea i've seen
families split up because a couple
people i know their mothers were sent
back to korea you know who we should
have on this podcast we should have um
um sam on here
sam
do you know this uh do you know him so
sam actually
was in korea
yeah he was born in the united states
this is this is he this is the opposite
story he was born
it's not funny
yeah it's not supposed to be funny i
just can't believe this
yeah it's crazy it's crazy born in the
united states goes to korea
right
so the thing is
if you are a korean citizen which i was
right
um i am now an american citizen i gave
up my citizenship in korea if you have
an active korean citizenship from south
korea
uh as a male you have to serve two years
in the military right so my brother when
he was 18 i was what 13 14 at the time
um we went to korea
um before i went uh went to high school
when we were leaving
two guys in korean military grabbed my
brother and dragged him away what the
[ __ ] because they're saying that he was
leaving the country without serving his
military dues so his time in the
military so my mom just going like what
the [ __ ] are you guys doing they're like
he's 18. he can't leave needs he's he
needs to serve his time in the military
so they were going to take him into the
military i remember this as a kid at the
airport because i had to carry like two
jars of kimchi
that we had to bring over in our
carry-on yeah
and they were just going to [ __ ] take
him away and then my mom went over there
she had to show proof
you know that he was only in the country
for two two weeks
because i think if you stay there past a
month
and you're a korean citizen and you have
a green card in the states you can get
taken to the military yeah but we were
only there for two weeks we were way
below that time limit yeah and so but
they try to take my brother away well
the story about sam sam goes to korea
right he was there for i think two weeks
two or like a week
and they dragged him away and they put
him in the military and they wouldn't
let him go home he was not born in korea
he was born in america i can't believe
that he just had to go through that he
wasn't a korean citizen whatsoever
the dude barely spoke korean and they
put him on the dmz
[ __ ] damn dude hilarious not funny yeah
it's just audacious yeah
what the [ __ ]
something happened either with paperwork
or something else something about a
family tree i forgot how it was
described to me by mutual friends but
he went and by the way too he was fat
yeah fat out of shape happy jolly good
guy surfer
serves military time in korea because of
some [ __ ] that happened doesn't
speak korean and he had joined the
korean [ __ ] military for two years
and he was born in america damn dude
could you imagine how [ __ ] funny of a
story is that for a film
you want to do a [ __ ] story justin do
that
how funny is that that [ __ ] like can
only be portrayed i mean this can't only
but then it's just like so
it like i said because it's so audacious
it can only be a comedy yeah yeah so i
mean let's start breaking down this film
a little bit right i mean obviously we
only saw it once it's a film that you're
if you enjoyed it or you felt weird
about it you should probably watch it
again it's it's just a lot to unpack
right because it is about a the the
adoptee story right there's a lot of
like these stories that aren't told that
i think the film was trying to tell the
story um
so the main character has a
a daughter-in-law because he's married
to a girl from louisiana
step-daughter oh yes
step-daughter yeah he's married to a
girl in louisiana she had a kid
with another guy who was the probably
the antagonist of the film yeah he was a
the police yeah he was a policeman he
was an [ __ ] in this film or
supposedly right yeah on props to the
the wife i can't believe they they got
her she's swedish too yeah she's uh ex
machina
yeah yeah
amazing actress yeah and so this
he's the film kind of in the first part
does something that i really really do
appreciate this is what we're talking
about his character backstory this
relationship that he has with his
daughter and like kind of how american
he is so
uh what's justin's character's name i
forgot antonio so antonio his name is
antonio leblanc yeah i believe right um
he is a clear depiction of what an
american is right an immigrant american
right who was born who wasn't born here
but was brought to this country but has
his whole american experience he even
has like that baton rouge like louisiana
the very he's a product of his
environment
yes yeah so justin does like this louis
he has like this louisiana draw to the
way that he speaks yeah and clearly he's
as
[ __ ] as it looks
right
yeah and that was the great justice
position to see someone like him
um
being this straight korean face but
putting on this louisiana bayou accent
this is america yeah and he just that
alone embodied what america is right
and um his character in this story is an
adoptee
um
doesn't
he has glimpses of who his mother is in
the beginning of the film right you kind
of see this woman and there is she
singing his song
like this this lullaby lullaby yeah yeah
and what you find out later on in the
film is that that lullaby is what his
mom was singing at the time when she
tried to kill him
yeah postpartum abortion yes
basically that's what it is yes right so
she tried to drown him yeah um
in a bayou
right in korea
before he was given up to adoption
so this is kind of like the ons
onslaught of his character and who he is
early in the film he kind of sets this
relationship up with his daughter
the the young actress the little girl
who played his daughter was so [ __ ]
good right yeah how amazing was she
everybody's acting was amazing
it was so good by the way this film is
uh shot in [ __ ] film right 60
millimeters i was actually reading up on
that did you see all the imperfections
like the dust
i was like oh [ __ ] i remember there was
a there was some article about him
pushing for it to be 35 yeah 16 but he
did a bunch of tests yeah something yeah
i think it was in 16 mil yeah that's
amazing so the film is shot on film it
looks really [ __ ] good it's beautiful
and once again
annie chang you definitely have huge
wanker y influences it's it's a lot
different than uh goo cause goo was
anamorphic he was on sticks a lot but uh
this one was had a it was like almost
documentary running gun style yeah right
yeah which is what i really actually
appreciate about what any chain can do
right i think a lot of the times because
of tech and how camera cameras can be
moved
in
new fun and unique ways the
classic idea of number one just leaving
stuff on sticks
leaving these huge wides or following
uh following the subject with a camera
opera walking with him
you know that art is kind of lost now
right a lot of the film and the bravado
that we enjoy about these new films is
how they film it with this new tech
right these
you know gimbals or whatever what not
um
his film style and the way he
envisions things is very raw yeah which
i think that's why justin really likes
anti a lot yeah and you see that too and
especially with such a heavy film that's
so dialogue heavy that's so story driven
this raw way of shooting like how they
handle the film how they frame these
shots i think it's very important and it
lends the film really well yeah you know
yeah it was it looked beautiful like
every shot really did show off like
just the environment very well um
because you know like you guys were
limited with your budget on google it
was like very women you guys shot on
like two blocks
[Laughter]
very limited locations
dude like um as i was watching i was
like damn i was like really happy that
justin got just so much opportunity to
just have different locations yeah just
watching it like yeah i'm glad he got a
house
you know so you you start to see this um
his character about like kind of who he
is and how down and out he is right now
because he's trying to get a job because
obviously so in this film he's having a
kid is on the way
um so he has his stepdaughter but he
also has his daughter that's going to be
on the way
uh with his wife
and he's struggling with money
he wants to get a new job
um but he has priors right so in the
beginning of the film off the jump he's
trying to get a job as a mechanic
and
just not giving him the chance
to but he works at a tattoo party which
is why you see him all tatted up here
and then later it was like also implied
that he didn't get an education yeah
he's also a felon yes there was a funny
moment where they're like so what did
you why were you a criminal before he's
like i was stealing motorcycles and he's
like trying to get this job as a
motorcycle mechanic
it's so [ __ ] funny so obviously he's
not going to get this job
but
uh there's a there's a relationship
thing that's being brought up where this
where this little girl clearly loves
justin and that's her dad she doesn't
have a relationship with their
biological father because he actually
decided to ditch her and he just left
that child alone and ran away right yeah
and clearly this town that they live in
is very small they know that they can
contact each other their father who is a
cop wants to be a part of this kid's
life this kid wants nothing to do with
him
right it's not his dad the dad that she
knows is actually uh antonio leblanc yes
and you see this like weird moment too
where the daughter kind of articulates
hey um
you're probably going to leave me just
like
that everybody else does right when the
baby's born yeah when the baby's born
you're going to forget about me and then
you know antonio has a very
heartfelt moment where they ditch school
right probably not a great job as a
parent you know
but he's you know trying to develop the
strong bond with his daughter saying
like i'm not going to leave you you're
still going to be important to me and
he's like listen like you chose me
that's just the same way that i choose
you i'm going to be around for you you
know kind of re kind of reaffirming this
bond and this love that they have for
each other which is it's going to be
super important throughout the whole
film well i thought that was also
important because like uh i think justin
was portraying that antonio's not a
perfect person
right so he he does a lot of bad
decisions which would explain why his
character is in this predicament in the
first place because of his priors
because he's been making a bunch of bad
decisions but it also touches on why
he's been making bad decisions
um and you see it a lot in adoptees look
i saw it in my dad my dad
was uh adopted
um and brought here when he was oh
that's right your dad was an adult i
mean this this story meant a lot to me
too insane because i could see
antonio labong's character i could see
that in my dad now granted my dad wasn't
raised by like white americans he was
raised by other koreans who immigrated
here
but um
did it remind you of your dad because
it's like a [ __ ] up still always trying
to do his message yes yes yeah yeah so
when was going back towards like the
reasons why he kept
antonio makes these bad decisions um it
makes perfect sense to me too um
whether it be a case of like a massive
fear of abandonment um and
like that entails people to
like oh you're gonna leave me
like having this self-fulfilling
prophecy like i'm gonna leave you before
you leave me so they'll make these
decisions
to draw people away from them you know i
had to learn about a lot of these things
because i was trying to understand my
dad yeah yeah you know and i like i get
it like he he was brought here when he
was 16 and they put him in the seventh
grade so i can understand my dad's major
angst and like intellectual
he was in the seventh grade when he was
the sixth biggest dude at virgil high
school dude
because he was like 20 by the time like
he got up there and it's just like man i
i'm a [ __ ] freshman i'm a sophomore
in twenty-one holy [ __ ] he just dropped
out yeah you know it's also embarrassing
for him yeah for real like uh so i can
understand why my dad like
went the wild as well i didn't know he
was he came here that late this podcast
is brought to you by babel my friends
when you're traveling to a destination
where you don't know the language it can
be challenging to accomplish even the
simplest of tasks i have traveled many
places where i couldn't speak anything
and i gotta tell you ordering a cup of
coffee was probably one of the biggest
nightmares of my life just me sitting
there just excuse me
does that sound like you that was me for
30 minutes at a cafe in taiwan
so thankfully there's babel the number
one selling language learning app
through babel's bite-sized lessons
you'll learn new language skills that
you can actually use in the world from
greetings menus and directions to
gaining a deeper understanding of the
culture babel is a travel essential
babel's 15 minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go plus babel speech recognition
technology helps you to improve your
pronunciation and accent so you don't
sound like an el stupido you know what
i'm saying milamo s whatever okay right
now when you purchase the three month
babel subscription you'll get an
additional three months for free that's
six months for the price of three just
go to babel.com and use promo code gb
that's b-a-b-b-e dot com code gb babble
language for life
yeah like
so that's that's what i thought my mom
always said he came at 13
and so i'm still really late though yeah
but 13 too that's that's late and then i
would assume he was in seventh grade
he's like no i was 16 and they put me in
seventh grade wow they're 13 year olds
so he was given up at 16.
no he was giving up at birth but then
they came here to america when he was
16. god yeah got you and so when he
found out he was adopted before they
immigrated to america they were like
uh you're adopted
you have a twin we're going to america
you're not going to meet him happy
birthday
[Laughter]
sounds about right yeah yeah it's like
what the [ __ ] yeah so so that's why this
movie you know i i was very in tune to
it you know as i was reading like that's
why i was breaking down like shanghi the
way i did because my dad
was not a good guy he was a gangster
yeah and looking at the way
shanghai was dealing with that was just
like you piece of [ __ ]
yeah
yeah you know like the the thing about
like i i hate to deviate but
you know the problem i had too was that
um
my dad going to prison
and and breaking a lot like selling
drugs this and that or whatever um
didn't make me look at him as a bad guy
it was my relationship with him and how
he treated me that made you that made
him me see him as a bad guy yeah so when
i was watching shanghai it's like okay
he
he murdered the people who murdered your
mom you know he is a gangster
but then like yo he treated you really
well you guys had a great relationship
so i mean we talked about that before
but
in in this film um
we see the bad decisions and you're like
what the [ __ ] and then they start slowly
picking apart his character his past and
like especially when he's at that
lawyer's office you know like the only
way you're gonna get this knowledge you
got to contact your mother yeah right
yeah and then his response like
showed him have this
what do you call it a
downward spiral yeah you start to see a
lot of the things that are happening to
him or
a lot of it is because of his personal
choices but also because of the
circumstances that he grew up in right
yes and so
later on in the film you see
the father um
trying to develop a relationship with
his stepdaughter stepdaughter doesn't
want anything to do with him um they're
in the grocery store
and they start getting into a fight and
an argument and it developed over the
fact that he didn't take her to school
right yeah and they're they're arguing
in the grocery store and it happens that
her biological father with his [ __ ]
fat partners cop pig partner he plays he
really plays the antagonist yeah really
hard you know
and he's you know he's just like this
dumb louisiana country bumpkin ass cop
that's hyper aggro
and starts [ __ ]
with antonio yeah right in his mind he's
doing it to like back up his friend
which is the father but
you could tell like the the father in
this film
doesn't like antonio
so when his partner starts doing bad
things to him
he
watches it happen but he knows it's
wrong yeah right
but he's also in desperation of wanting
to see
his daughter and obviously having this
other strange man who's not a white man
is an asian guy raising this kid is
making him feel a certain way so his his
dumb partner
decides to report him to ice
right yeah well first he he arrests him
for no good reason and then in the show
beat him up throw him in jail they
postponed but then he already reported
him to ice so now he
uh antonio is in this predicament where
now he's going to get deported yeah
right and so the film house
they find a lawyer they get lawyered up
and he takes 5 000 up front yes so
they they kind of show
the how hard it is to prove that you are
so one of the ways that you can stay in
this country too is
obviously prove
how long you've been here or whatever
uh
and then
you you've one of the best ways to do it
and the film kind of touches this as
well is that if you gain asylum through
like being a refugee right through like
a war-torn country you know
he was an adoptee that came here
not it wasn't like a vietnam cambodia
khmer rouge situation you know he's
south korean yeah
so he was just a kid that was probably
at an orphanage at the time and he got
adopted yeah and it was a story that
their parents his parents didn't file
the paperwork yes parents didn't follow
the paperwork which wasn't his fault
yeah and so now he's being and then on
top of that he has a rap sheet he's a
felon
so it kind of shows that he's not a
productive member of society so in order
for them to even have this lawyer work
with him and he has his work cut out for
him he needs five thousand dollars well
what the [ __ ] is this guy gonna get five
thousand dollars right he was already
trying to make more money because of the
new baby on the way so now he's down the
hole exactly so um
when he was at the hospital we forgot
about the scene um there was a
vietnamese lady there that kind of he
starts striking up a conversation with
her
and he sees his daughter trying to get a
snack out she helps them out get the
snack out it kind of starts this
relationship with them so because now he
needs to make money fast
he prints out these pink flyers where
he's like out in the streets just like
who needs a tattoo who needs a tattoo
yeah trying to beg people to get a
tattoo so he could pay for the stuff by
the way too he hasn't even paid his
chair fees at the tattoo parlor so he's
already so [ __ ] down that he's
actually in depth yes and so at this
point it's just it was so
it was hard for me to watch that it was
heavy-handed it was so heavy-handed like
watching this guy just beg
just somebody i mean you're trying to
sell tattoos
it was so sad right but he's trying to
be better i think that's why it was so
hard for me to watch right like just
watching somebody on the street just beg
for [ __ ] work yeah it's it's a
difficult thing he's trying but he has
like no options exactly
he meets
the the woman that he met at the
hospital when uh his wife was getting
the ultrasound the woman that helped
rattle the snack out of the uh the snack
machine and she goes i need a tattoo
and he goes oh are you serious like what
kind of tattoo you want you know
whatever he's like kind of shocked that
she wants to get a tattoo
gives her a tattoo during their
conversation well like she takes her wig
off to get on a motorcycle and she it's
shown that she is a cancer patient right
and then you're she's getting her tattoo
and then she explains that she's what
stage four much right
and then so
there's the juxtapo
tresposition between these two
immigrants you know one being adopted
facing deportation
and one who was a refugee and is
settling in america and also facing
death and dying here yeah right
so that's kind of where
you start to see their relationship
develop over time right and you you kind
of wonder like what is the importance of
this person in this film like why is she
even here
right like is it the show just uh not
just antonio that hey you don't really
have it that bad like what is the
purpose of her right well you see later
on in the film and we're kind of jumping
around
i only got to see this film once i'm
gonna have to watch it again
um she's vietnamese
and she he decides to give her this
tattoo for free
right he finds out about her story even
if he's down and out and this actually
is a reflection of that he's actually a
really good guy yeah you know sees that
she's this woman who's in pain she's
going to pass away and she gets the
louisiana sign which is a flower it's
very corny and tacky yeah and he was
like i'm going to pay you for this he
goes no no no don't your money's no good
here shows that he's a really good
person she says
well if you're not going to take this we
throw family parties which every
vietnamese [ __ ] person knows family
parties are [ __ ] fire as [ __ ]
and invites him over to a family party
yeah with his uh wife
uh and kid or whatever
they go to this party and they go to
this vietnamese party i think this was
like a very important part because
antonio doesn't know what family is
right not only that like he he says i
feel like i'm in asia yeah he's
uncomfortable
with like he like he's so american he
doesn't understand the the live band and
singing like karaoke-ish thing even the
the
the spring roll is a little weird to him
and all this stuff like he needs to take
a breather like
um like how do i eat this [ __ ] right
he's asian yeah
it was showing how like if he can't take
this how could he go back to korea yeah
well he doesn't know what goddamn thing
yeah yeah it's he was he was a fish out
of water in a situation where he should
where people would normally feel
comfortable when they see people who
look just like him yeah which in
juxtaposition shows how [ __ ] american
he is he is an adoptee that identifies
with being an american person and so
when he sees people who came to this
country but still holds on to their
cultural identity it's weird to him yeah
you know like it's like he's never
experienced this [ __ ] didn't know how to
make the spring roll there was like
these really great moments where he's
doing the spring roll thing and this
other this little asian girl smiling and
teaching him how to eat it she's like yo
this food's actually really good yeah
it's like a white person eating asian
food for the first time yeah
you know i thought that was really
awesome because you know like what i
said where i grew up um it was a bunch
of like a lot of white people and i was
in the sticks
but
here's the thing i wasn't the only asian
person at my high school there was like
i'm going to say
up to 10 different asians that were all
adopted
oh for real yeah i was the only so
here's the thing i was the only like
asian american like where my parents
immigrated and i was grew up and wow
everyone else like were
had white parents they were adopted and
grew up in these sticks
and
like even i couldn't connect with them i
wasn't i was hardly friends with any of
them because the way they talked about
being asian was a joke
you know the way white people around
them they would look at you and go
they would pull back their already asian
eyes and look at you it's like you're me
really i i felt like
that that was one of the weird identity
issues i had growing up out there was
that
even though there were these other
asians i couldn't talk to them they
could have just been white really and
some of them too especially one dude
didn't want anything to do with other
asian people didn't want to identify he
really wanted to just
be white white yeah and just be with the
other students and just don't even
mention that i'm asian kind of thing you
know so being asian there was no real
conversation about it being different
there was no conversation
everyone had their different complexes
yeah it was a weird situation for me so
like
why this movie is so important is that
it shows it still shows one aspect of
what it's like
you know that that's something that
truly touches deep in the asian american
experience that they're not all just
like us who have immigrant asian
american parents because those guys
don't have to identify with us at all to
be honest
and it was a bit refreshing to see that
that while he identifies as american you
know um everyone else
everyone else just does not accept him
that way yeah and i i'm pretty sure
that's what a lot of the adoptees
felt that all the white people didn't
accept them but in turn they didn't
accept me yeah yeah yeah yeah that was a
weird uh complexity so the relationship
he has with the vietnamese lady with
cancer was very interesting to me to see
how he interacts with someone who is
like asian immigrant i feel like i'm not
sure if this was like the purpose of
what they were doing but it was almost
like she fulfilled a motherly role that
he always wanted but never had and her
father
that's why he he was constantly asking
him questions like do you regret
what you're leaving and splitting up the
family splitting up the family yeah and
he says i have no regrets
you know because when you're looking at
throughout this film is going to a lot
of flashbacks about the time his mother
tried to kill him when he was younger
and he even talks about in the film like
he doesn't tell people this but he and
he doesn't tell people until later on
but he told her and revealed to her i
actually do remember my mom and i
remember my mom's face and i remember
her trying to kill me
you know which is so [ __ ] heavy and
so i think when he asks
when he's asking these questions to her
father i think he's asking him questions
that he would ask his mother
you know do you regret
giving me up do you regret trying to
kill me you know yeah and for it you
know when he was getting these answers
from the father figure it's almost like
he was getting answers from his mother
or a parental figure that he never
really had yeah right and so later on in
the film
um
the lawyer kind of breaks it down to
them like listen your chances are
[ __ ] slim and none we need to have
witnesses to show that you're an amazing
person that you're a good person that
you're a productive person in society
and one of the ways to do is have family
members do it
uh specifically his adopted family his
adopted family members just vouched for
him to vouch for him yeah
so i i'm i could be making this up i'm
not sure but he had an adopted family
that gave him up and then went to this
family after
well no the adoptive family were
neglectful he ended up in different
foster care foster care system and they
ended up with this family yeah and so
his wife doesn't know anything about
this his whole life he told his wife
that they died and so she didn't know
until the lawyer brought it up he goes
hey i looked up you said your family
died like you don't have any
uh you know your foster or your adopted
parents aren't alive well says that
you're i looked it up and your mother's
still alive yeah she found out that he
lied to him so she doesn't even know who
this guy is anymore it's like who who
the [ __ ] are you it shows that he's so
self-destructive
in order to avoid that drama yeah
because he doesn't want to touch it with
a hundred foot pole yeah right it this
could [ __ ] save you and he's just
like [ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah and it's not
even just save him he made promises to
his wife and his daughter that he was
gonna stay around and be a good husband
and a good father yeah but it's
there's clearly this moral point where
he his priority is his family but his
self-preservation is now
in constant battle with this right he's
like i will do anything to save my
family but this and we as an audience
don't really [ __ ] know why and you
kind of get disappointed oh i thought
you were a good dude what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you yeah and you see in a
fight
where they explode
um and she wants absolutely nothing to
do with him especially after he lied
about that she's gonna move and go back
with her with her mother his
mother-in-law that [ __ ] hates him
already yeah and there's this huge
moment where they clash she goes i don't
know this this scene by the way very
powerful that's such good acting yeah
you know what i mean i felt like i was
watching a real couple fight scene in
the kitchen yes yeah
yeah that was that was pretty
wow wow he brought it out
and he finally reveals he goes hey you
don't know everything about me because i
didn't tell you about my my foster
parents because
by foster dad beat the living [ __ ] out
of me every [ __ ] day yeah and i
left
i left these people they treated me
terribly i was from foster home the
foster home came here was adopted they
didn't they didn't love me and then i
went to another foster home another
foster home these people didn't love me
they gave up on me gave up on me i
finally went to a family and then these
people beat the living [ __ ] out of me
every day i can't go back to this person
it brings up too much pain
but for her she's like i'm your wife
you couldn't even trust me then there's
no trust here yeah and her heart's
broken
he eventually decides that he is going
to go
to
um
well this is
first the the lady he's at the the
tattoo
shop he decides that uh
the vietnamese lady comes through and
says she wants another tattoo he treats
her like a [ __ ] [ __ ] he's going
through emotional stuff get the [ __ ] out
of here like so when when he heard he
had to go to that that uh
foster parent
uh he had he had a breakdown
um he spiraled out
uh went crazy on his bike
then uh
shows up to work and he has no money for
his booth right oh that's right so he's
already feeling like [ __ ] and then the
lady shows up and he's like
i'm not a [ __ ] charity
and then he totally just rejects her and
that's what i mean about
that that complex with abandonment is
that before you abandon me i'm gonna
depend on you first yeah and it's there
and the also thing that kind of dams him
in his wife's eyes is
he got that five thousand dollars
because he robbed the motorcycle store
uh dope [ __ ] sequence by the way
amazing yeah how [ __ ] dope was that
when he blasted out through the through
through the [ __ ] glass and just
ditched and he [ __ ] jetted reynolds
has a has an article out there about how
he edited that scene too oh that scene
was so [ __ ] amazing dude yeah like it
shows his desperation like it shows like
how far he's been broke my [ __ ] chode
was tight i was like dude get the [ __ ]
out of there the cops are coming the
cops are coming because the thing was
that
he got enough cars or enough motorcycles
that almost paid through it but if you
got a ducati ducati yeah it was like a
thousand dollars or something or two
thousand or something cut yeah
it was a way for that enough
yeah and he decided that he got it he
jetted out escape with it and he got the
money he got the five thousand dollars
but he got out with his visor up yeah
yeah yeah and so guess who was at the
scene
her uh biological father biological
father the baby daddy yeah the baby
daddy was there he sees his face he
knows it's him
um
[Music]
the eyes man yeah it always gives it
away right yeah
i think that's kind of a hilarious not
hilarious but like
like the right
thing that like the visor being up
identifying him because of his eyes like
yeah but not that oh it could have been
any asian guy but it's like in his
situation it's him yeah
yeah i only know one dude and i've seen
those [ __ ] hd vision eyes
those [ __ ] wide screen eyes king 16 9
[ __ ] yeah you 69 eyed
[ __ ]
recognizes him such an amazing [ __ ]
cool scene and it just kind of damns him
because it goes
[ __ ]
you're willing to go ahead and risk your
life going to jail breaking into this
[ __ ] do all this crime to get this five
thousand dollars to get this lawyer but
you're not even willing to go see your
mother this woman that you lied to me
about that would literally save our
[ __ ] family makes him look like a
piece of [ __ ]
he finally decides to go see his mother
um
[Music]
confronts her
because she basically um
oh in the lawyer's office said like oh
i'll talk to him if he if he wants to
come out he wants to talk to me
and he just said he's like you get to
see through the dialogue why he holds
resentment towards his foster mom
it's because
he was abandoned so many times in his
life he actually let he actually loved
his foster mom it was the one person
that he loved despite that they had the
shitty father he goes i protected you
16 years of my [ __ ] life i took
beatings for you i protected you and
when i asked you to come with me when i
left you decided to stay with him yeah
hurt just [ __ ] pain yeah and no
answers either
she did not speak she was one character
important character who had no lines i
said why he goes i don't know yeah but
it was important like cause some things
like that [ __ ]
you're just not gonna get the [ __ ]
answers if you've been in this kind of
predicament where you really need to
know the answers from someone and then
it's it's either sometimes you don't
yeah you're just not gonna get the
answer sometimes and you have to live
with that [ __ ] and
that was a pain that
i can understand
yeah
yeah yeah no i thought yeah that was
good [ __ ] dude it was just so poignant
you know it's like i wish that part was
explored a little more but i felt like
it was still very impactful um
just with her not having an answer and
also too when people are abused by
people with their by their abuser
they don't know why they stick around
sometimes whether it's like an emotional
attachment
or or sometimes even people in those
predicaments like in that situation you
think about socioeconomic situation and
domestic abuse where would she go do
they understand stockholm syndrome yeah
you know do they even know how to
explain why
literally it's just they don't know
either i don't know i stayed yeah they
just have these make these decisions
yeah and i feel bad for them right it's
like
like i said
foster home to foster home to foster
phone this misfit nobody wanted him his
original mom tried to kill him doesn't
want him goes to another place
to another country get adopted wasn't
good enough finally finds a family gets
beaten every day and the one person that
he actually loved which was his mom i
would have done anything to protect her
got his ass beat for her and asked hey i
need you to come with me let's start
this new life she chooses
abandons him as well yep right and so
that's why it was so important for him
when he was saying i choose you i chose
your mom that means i choose you too
that's why it was so
like that that was important to him yeah
because uh i'm gonna bring it back to
the abandonment complex is that
when you stick by somebody you are
[ __ ] right or died like the literal
meaning of it and he was like i choose
you and that's why he went through the
links he went through right
so next part of the film he actually
does reconnect with the lady who has
cancer
um decides to give her the tattoo and
they have a moment where they ride out
and they have a long conversation um i
think it was at a dock at a river yeah
and
you know they're opening up revealing
things about him and he reveals to her
that i actually do remember he goes i
think i was drawn to you because you
look like my mom mm-hmm i do remember i
when i first saw her i was like is that
his mom
you know
secret oprah reveals yeah
but it's not you know and they they have
a heart to heart and he feels this
connection towards her because she looks
like his mom or what he remembers of his
mom
and you know he's revealing stuff to her
that we're not privy to until later in
the film um they get on this motorcycle
and she is in very bad shape yeah
she's on the motorcycle her wig flies
off
and that part
laughs so hard
like oh [ __ ]
it wasn't supposed to be funny but in my
mind i was like that wig better not fly
off but you know i i really feel like
that was like a uh reinterpretation
because i've seen that in korean media
where um a guy is giving someone obuba
you know you eat piggy back right and
then they go limp you know because
whatever korean cancer like some risk
cancer that they had yeah they died they
died from or whatever i had a hair
cancer yeah i thought it was pretty
clever how he brought that into this
asian-american film yeah yeah there's a
specific film that i really really like
with um
eaton
[ __ ] i'm forgetting his name
holy [ __ ] he's like one of my favorite
korean actors korean
god damn it but there's a movie called
and it's a kid who has cancer um
and
this woman who he hooked up with years
ago says that this kid is his and this
kid finds him
says that that's his father or whatever
right
um
i don't think this kid knows that his
mom is dead or something right from what
i remember
and he goes on this journey to find his
mom but they find out that i think he
finds out that the mom is dead but he
still continues his journey with this
kid but he hates this kid by the way
he's like you're not my son yeah you
know he tries to avoid him but he's like
unavoidable because very persistent but
in the last end of the film you see him
falling in love with his child and at
the end he's over buying him on the side
of the road as they're traveling across
the world
dies as he's piggybacking him and you
can feel him go limp and he's just
sobbing and crying as he's still
carrying him on his back so it was like
i've seen that in the korean films it's
very very sad yeah but
yeah he he he basically is for with this
woman until her last dying breath during
this time his wife who was pregnant who
kicked them out
is having a child
yeah their child is born
um
which kind of sucked because he wasn't
there for it right because he was kicked
out of the house because his
quote-unquote choices yeah um
later on in the film
you find out that uh they have a set
court date he reveals to her that hey i
talk to my mom it kind of mends their
relationship
um because now she feels that he's
putting in the effort to do what he can
to stay a part of this family he has a
court date that's coming up
he doesn't make it
because of the [ __ ]
cop buddy buddy yeah decide that he was
going to do a favor for his friend the
baby's daddy
and make sure that he doesn't reach this
court date and he beats the [ __ ] out of
him in this like remote forest somewhere
kidnaps him and beats the [ __ ] out of
him misses the court date
his mom actually does decide to show up
there everybody's waiting there
um and you see like a character moment
in um
the the baby's dad where she goes like
what the [ __ ] are you doing here and
he's like
if he leaves my family leaves too so i'm
here he actually doesn't know what's
happening over there yeah i like that
that character had a lot more nuance
than just being the straight antagonist
but they put it on his partner
but then the fact that like
the reasons for his motives are is love
he wants to be around his daughter yeah
you know yeah so
it humanizes him you know he's not just
out there to hate him because he's an
asian guy or whatever he just wants to
see his daughter yeah right and he's
kind of living with the mistakes that he
made abandoning them and now he's trying
to make up for it his daughter doesn't
want to see him his his the mother of
the mother of his daughter doesn't want
to see him nobody wants anything to do
with him and he just has his [ __ ]
partner who's trying to help do him
favors but really he's just a [ __ ]
dick yeah um misses his court date
and antonio has to walk back find his
motorcycle somewhere or whatever whereas
motorcycle was at the diner and drive
back in the rain
tries to come and talk to his wife she
wants nothing to do with him but she
doesn't know what's happened to him yeah
so he's begging banging on the door like
let me in let me in i have to tell you
something has nothing and then he just
starts
riding off in the rain with his busted
ass arm and his busted body
yeah and he just loses everything
everyone's abandoned him now he's
literally left
alone yes
saddest [ __ ] ever that i've ever seen
right and now he has to
make this choice where he has to i think
he kind of came to terms with the
situation and now he's really trying to
do the right thing for the family and so
he decides that he's going to leave
and there's
he's going to give them money before he
leaves and he sells his motorcycle
to the guy that he that would help him
rob [ __ ]
leaves the money at the doorstep
said this and she sees the note notices
that he this is this this is clean
[ __ ] money yeah knows that he's gonna
leave well before this he the the
partner reveals to the baby's dad that
he's the reason why he didn't make the
court date i did you a [ __ ] favor
and
he doesn't know about this he's shocked
he goes cool he's pissed
because he knows that his family's going
to leave yeah he goes you [ __ ] this
all up for me if he leaves my family's
going to leave with him i'll never see
my daughter ever again so he gets his
ex to beat the [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] you i'm gonna get my wife
to beat you up
[Laughter]
that was such a good scene yeah her
beating the [ __ ] out of him
really made i was like she's such a good
[ __ ] actress dude like i really felt
all of her emotions you know she's
frustrated she's trying to contact him
and now at this point
um
he went through a moment too by the way
before this i'm sorry i skipped this
part where he's like given up on like
he's abandoned by everybody he's in the
rain he's he's writing in it and he
tries to kill himself right by going
into the bible this is where you get to
see a glimpse
of his mother this scene by the way
amazing
so it was the underwater scene yeah
where he's in this water and he's
drowning you think he's going to die and
you see this moment where his mother
comes down and he's seeing flashes of
his mom trying to reach out and save him
and you get to see this past history i'm
not sure if i'm messing up the timeline
but this past history of
his mother actually regretting trying to
kill him yeah she's like what have i
done yeah and then when he kind of wakes
up from this moment he's back up there
he's sitting around he doesn't die yeah
he actually doesn't kill himself fun
fact for you guys when you watch this
film
they shot that scene
at the after party
what
why was there a pull at the top to party
to pull at the after party it's like we
need this shot and and then auntie the
director was like let's just get the
shot let's see what happens and they
shot it at the pool in the after party
and it went into the film when the film
was already wrapped it was already
wrapped and then it was a pickup shot
yeah
yeah that was important last call yeah
how [ __ ] amazing yeah was that scene
how great was it yeah it was a
last-minute call i didn't know and they
told me that that was a very important
scene first yeah because it it it ties
into
like
the whole thing with like not going
through with it or whatever yeah
that he still deserves a life right
despite the fact of everything he's
going through he's still going to live
and then he he brings that back to
himself in in a modern time yeah
and at this point too like i feel like
in his situation for his character
he is now in a position where he could
end this cycle of hurt
he could do the right thing
you know i know he wants to bring his
family to korea or whatever but it's not
what's best for the daughter it's not
what's best for his wife either yeah
it's what's for what he wants yeah you
know so he decides to get the money
right sells sells the motorcycle
gets the money it drops it off saying
this is this is clean money don't worry
about it and get to the airport
and then they're they're leading him off
and then um
i thought this part was important
because they they catch him at the
airport
um but the the baby daddy shows up too
right
and
baby daddy thinks that they're trying to
leave with him to korea right yeah and
this is what the stepdaughter said was
like you're gonna leave me when the
baby's born right and it was because she
said you cried when you saw oh that's
right the the
thing right you never cry for me yeah
you won't cry for me
and then
when they get to the airport he's like
no don't come this is a bad idea
whatever and it's like you guys got to
stay like stay with your dad this is
your daddy or whatever right and he
walks off with with the police or ice
towards the gate
and then when he looks back and he sees
that she's not crying
and
her
her dad's our bio dad's arms and he
realized that no it's like she chooses
me
right she says i choose you don't go
right and then [ __ ] cried out
everything dude everybody in the theater
falling down there's so many people
sniffling like
yeah
even i'm like goddamn yeah it was such a
heartfelt scene when he came up and the
kid was just begging for her father
right and
you know the reason this is what we talk
about character development a lot right
yeah
scenes like this matter because of the
relationship that was established with
father and stepdaughter yeah let's just
say father and daughter at this point
it mattered it mattered so [ __ ] it
was a pincer move right between these
two people and everything like you
seeing the story happen and the way they
see it in their perspective it's all
going to meet just for this moment right
here and it's going to matter you have
to understand like if you ever walked
through an airport and you saw a couple
hugging and they're crying
it it you get it it looks beautiful you
don't know what's going on before this
movie is showing like what this [ __ ]
means
you know and that literally [ __ ]
touched my soul i think too like there's
also a scene that i forgot there's
little gems like this that kind of
builds up the payoff right for example
there was a part in the scene where you
could tell how strong their relationship
is because there's this funny-ass scene
in the movie where the daughter decides
to dye her hair black yeah and it's all
[ __ ] up because she wanted to look
like her dad yeah which is antonio yeah
and then he's trying to laugh not laugh
it's like no you look beautiful baby
girl you know like you look [ __ ]
beautiful
she looks like a [ __ ] dirty mop on
her head dirty she's balling her eyes
out and then he says like he'll do
anything to make her happy or whatever
what not and she wants him to dye his
hair
a funny color and that's why he has that
weird pink hair yeah um it's because
that's what his daughter asked which
shows like this beauty in their
relationship they are father and
daughter despite what they look like
despite anything else that's the
relationship they chose each other yeah
and you then you see that love and so
that final scene was such a good payoff
and it's important to show that like
what it means to choose just to love
somebody
right despite their flaws or whatever
you're not even blood or something like
they literally it's like i choose you i
chose you and he even like kind of calls
back to wander did you see that yet one
division i saw a couple of episodes i've
been watching and i want to ruin it for
you then yeah don't don't rule for me
because i
i just got done with loki so i have to
finish that too yeah yeah you got to see
that yeah yeah a
similar kind of scene like where it
speaks to me because of
you know i understand like i keep
bringing up abandonment issues because
i'll be honest here on this podcast i i
i had to go through a lot of therapy to
deal with these things and the behaviors
that i have
when it comes to that and what i have to
be cognitive about when i'm caught in a
situation like where i'm like
you know forget this person forget this
person forget this person i always have
to sit and choose and be like
i have to sit i have to choose and
decide that i'm going to stay with this
person i'm going to be around this
person i'm going to be a friend to this
person
you know despite all this [ __ ] i
don't [ __ ] need you know but then
ultimately in love like you you do have
to choose this and it's like i'm here
with you unconditionally through and
through yeah and i felt that that doing
that
traded like
so well in this movie in that scene yeah
and it's also too the idea of what
family is
and what a parent is isn't just you
being related by blood yes your actions
who are you how are you involved in this
child's life that makes you apparent
like that the concept of i choose you
yeah you know yondu and star-lord
he may have been your father because he
wasn't your daddy exactly yeah and and
it really did a beautiful job on that
part you know so i there wasn't a
[ __ ] dry eye in that in that theater
yeah everybody was [ __ ] crying um if
we want to talk about stuff that you
know i read a couple of reviews about
why people
were critical of it um once again
there's no film that's perfect there's
also going to be different opinions
about how they feel about things
and um one of the biggest critiques of
the film is that they felt it was over
dramatized it was hyper dramatic and it
was just in your face like hardcore
about like how much this sucks yeah
which i i did understand because one of
the one of the reviews that i read that
cracked me up they're like of course
there's a [ __ ] lady with cancer
you know
i was like i get it though i think that
opinion is very valid there was a lot
there was a few things in the film where
i felt like maybe we didn't need him to
try to kill himself
you know get beat up in the forest and
do all this other stuff like it it was
like one after another it was just
[ __ ] [ __ ] it was it was like
you know i mean i don't want to compare
to the holocaust but it's like you know
schindler's list yeah you can't watch it
like back you know i can enjoy it
exactly you watch it because of
you know
the purpose it has to show you how
[ __ ] up [ __ ] is yeah certain people
felt like okay this is just my god man
yeah
what like how much more drama do we need
like there was already enough where the
payoff was great it's like how many
times have you seen 12 years of slave
just once exactly yeah i don't think i'm
gonna put it on again it's too [ __ ] up
yeah it's very hard to watch yeah you
know it's important it's relevant it's
it's real i mean and it yeah yeah these
are they're important things but then
it's just things that are hard to
swallow because on film it's so visceral
like compared to just reading it off a
script yeah exactly so it's um
i understand that i think that criticism
is fair and i agree too when i was
watching it too i was like
i probably could have done with a little
bit without
the cancer lady but at the same time too
i do understand why she's there though
yeah because there was a purpose it had
to be the father's perspective in his
positivity after everything that's been
so [ __ ] up and now his daughter has
cancer yeah that's why he keeps going
back to the father to try to communicate
with him like what do you regret do you
regret this do you regret this he's
looking for something yeah so once again
it does make sense but very very
heavy-handed and i can understand why
some people might have rolled their eyes
like oh my god like what is this like a
very dramatized korean drama
like maybe maybe yeah you know and i
think that criticism is very fair yeah
um but one thing to say it's like it's a
very asian-american film like we're
we're the newest immigrants here right
yeah we our parents have seen some
[ __ ] [ __ ] our grandparents lived
through war too i mean and i think it
was also important why they showed the
vietnamese americans because they're
fresh off the boat from some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] too right
and and
we relate to a lot of tragedy
right and it's not like we enjoy tragedy
but it's part of our story whether we
want to run away from it or not it's
literally part you know the korean
adoptee story or just the adoptee story
is pretty intense you know and i think
like through this film like a lot of
people probably didn't know about the
situation like we do you know because we
are korean and we're asian americans
that know about people who have been
deported or who have been um in fear of
getting deported yeah and
the story isn't really told
and i think the film did a great job in
telling and people are going to be aware
of it so hopefully it did its good job
and in this in this episode or in the
description uh of this episode you'll
see a link to
you know these adoptee stories and how
we can help
you know yeah i mean like
we don't get these kind of stories i
can't think of any other film that has a
story like this yeah and i think that's
a lot of what uh justin tries to touch
right like even with [ __ ]
um
when we see the la riot story how many
times do we see it in our perspective
yeah right and he showed our the the
asian-american the korean-american
experience in the riots yeah you know a
story that not a lot of people hear of
what was like on our side and
i
if you guys can recommend movies that
have like these stories like this i have
not seen one like yeah like blue by you
to be honest and i think that's why i
commend justin because he's always out
there looking for a story that hasn't
been told yeah yeah i think like
one of the things i guess like the film
has been getting flack
and i have to touch on this too because
people are going to want me to talk
about this
um i don't know too much about this but
i feel like i think like there's a
little bit of backlash because like the
korean you know when you tell other
people's stories
and they don't get to tell it themselves
i think there's always going to be
backlash for this yeah um
and there has been a little bit about
that is it the tweet about
why was why didn't you hire a korean
adoptee actor to play i think there was
one of those two yeah yeah there's a few
of those okay yeah
that's the one i saw yeah
there's that there's
you know like this is very similar to
another korean adoptee story like did
you give them credit for it these are
things that i don't know you know
i do know that they did at the end there
was photos of real people yeah and there
was you know and i'm
i mean knowing justin too i'm almost 100
sure he reached out and had
conversations with people and
but once again like i don't know these
things um
all i know is that in this film i'm not
saying this from a precisely because i'm
his friend and i know him i just don't
know
um
but what i do know is that a lot of
people who did watch this film didn't
know about the situation
and when they saw the film
they were enlightened they go holy [ __ ]
this is so [ __ ] up yeah it's a story
that a lot of people don't know right
and it's happened to a lot of people
yeah it's it's kind of intense man uh
and we talk about legacy and i think as
a filmmaker this stuff creates legacy
because it creates important
conversations not every film has to be
this by the way one of my favorite films
ever is nacho libre oh my god yeah yeah
my favorite movie of all time
not all films have to be like this right
but for uh a drama
this is up there for me i love it it's
very personal
you know it kind of uh touches on
something that i that we all grew up
with that we know about i i don't know
if i've
told this on the podcast i've told you
but
i have an uncle
who spent 25 years
in the federal prison system here in
america oh that's right and uh if you
want to know
what you get sentence what you did to
earn 25 years in prison yeah he did that
[ __ ] yeah you know um but here's the
thing as soon as he served his time they
deported him right back to korea [ __ ]
you know and he he spent a few years
here in america
did some [ __ ] spent 25 years in prison i
remember visiting him
like when i was like four or five years
old
in my mind i thought that was his job
because he wasn't like in a jumpsuit i
thought he was like a mechanic or
something that's so funny because we
drive like two hours to go visit uncle
yeah you know at his work and fix these
cars already they're so lazy
it's like why didn't they come you know
to our parties or whatever wow 25 years
25 years can you imagine losing 25 years
of your life no
not at all dude um i i just heard the
amanda knox story and she spent four
years in italian prison i can't imagine
my own uncle what he went through for 25
years in the u.s prison system
but yeah they deported him
and
uh when he
he was in korea and i went and visited
him
man spitting image of my heart apogee he
looks just like him
he sees me he's like oh my god he
thought that i was my dad
that's so [ __ ] funny dude like for me
i thought i saw a ghost yeah but um yeah
uh he's a pastor there now he does
prison ministry
specifically he picks up
these
adoptees or first-gen like immigrants
like you that say you committed a felony
or something you spend some time present
and they just deport you right after
he picks up a lot of those kids so i
went to his halfway home where he houses
these
these these these people
it's the saddest environment i've ever
been to
i
if he was asking me to stay over there i
was like nah i'm just gonna sit here for
a while they're just sitting there like
i can't believe i'm in korea yeah dude
these dudes look so depressed and bummed
out
and some of them a few of them like just
kind of accepted that this is where they
live this is where they are but you know
they're just dude they're all guys these
dudes and
they have all this family in america but
they're just stuck here and then my
uncle's like yeah he's from illinois
he's from you know virginia he's from
california or whatever and there are all
these dudes who committed felonies spent
time in prison
and then got deported
and even one guy has just had this like
white foamy [ __ ] on his mouth because he
just didn't give a [ __ ] about what he
looked like anymore you know
like damn these are just depressed like
i'm here in korea i don't know what
goddamn [ __ ] thing about korea that's
because they didn't go to gangnam they
don't know how fun it is but they're
broke too oh that's right never mind bro
your situation sucks
yeah seriously be an english teacher bro
i don't know if i was there longer than
like you know 30 minutes
but i was like i gotta get out of here
this is depressing yeah and i didn't
know a goddamn thing about them like
dude can you get me a slim jim
so i know what it's like to be american
again can you get me some gardenos chips
like oh you want to go to mcdonald's
then we have mcdonald's right yeah
that's the saddest thing i've ever heard
dude it feels so bad but
that's uh my uncle's ministry out there
now he's just like
taking in a bunch of deportees
what do you do at that point man like
you're in a country you don't speak the
language all your family's in the states
you don't identify with being a korean
and by the way when you're in korea too
and you're a kilpo or something they
don't [ __ ] [ __ ] with you like that
mm-hmm you know you're not especially if
you're an ex-felon and you're an ex-con
and then you get some back korea yeah
like a piece of [ __ ] america not sending
us their best yeah no no
like we said you are best what the [ __ ]
yeah you know why you sent him that we
sent him to you now you're sending back
who brings it back a city
but that's you could see it in their
face that's what they felt like yeah
just abandoned left out just kicked out
separated from the family let's do a
movie about your uncle dude yeah well
here's this is why i feel comfortable
saying it because he wrote a [ __ ]
book okay well that's good
so that's the thing i i need to ask him
if he has an english translation of his
book but that's fine the crane was out
there
yeah and i mean like and he's just had
wild [ __ ] stories in prison too you
know oh my god dude prison stories are
scared of the [ __ ] out of me i can't do
prison bro like if somebody tries to
frame me for some [ __ ] it's like and i'm
like i gotta kill myself now 25 years i
can't do it i can't even do two weeks
yeah i can't do a week five days i can't
do none of it
yeah i mean i'm literally thinking like
his parole whatever he faced he did the
minimum 25. jesus yeah so that's like
yeah he speaks perfect english and he
speaks korean as well but then
you know my my mom helped support him
that was part of the things of me like
working at the store was just like this
is helping support uncle out there you
know so
wow this is the kind of work i do so
that's why this movie really touched
a piece of like of
story like that we don't hear and that
i finally saw on the screen that i
really just give props to justin for
doing
be honest yeah well guys that wraps up
this episode of the review of blue
by you it's like the saddest podcast i
know
if you haven't checked out the film i do
highly recommend it might not be a
everybody's cup of tea but it's
important stories and also two like
asian american films that just
you know just you just don't see every
now and then like you don't get to see
how great asian actors can be asian
writers asian d this if you want to talk
about an asian ass film this film asian
as [ __ ] yeah right yeah reynolds asian
american annie chang uh taiwanese
justin chan asian american yeah right
this is an asian american film about an
asian american story
it's really [ __ ] dope man like um
once again if you don't like it i get it
give it a chance give it a go imagine uh
it was a story at the end so
the beginning of the movie he's deported
korea and then the movies about him is
his life in korea
that's chang-chi
that's why everybody hates you bro
well guys that wraps up this episode you
can find ed at ed parkvp on instagram
give him a follow hit them up with
questions uh genius brains every
thursdays and sundays up until this uh
end of december january 1st is when we
start
once a week but who knows
that's how it is right now we got other
big projects coming up so i got to slow
down but i'm not going to stop doing the
podcast you just won't get it twice a
week now uh starting next year
so
thank you guys for tuning in and we'll
see you all next time peace peace